- [narrator] When Donald Trump
nominated Amy Coney Barrett
to replace Ruth Bader
Ginsburg on the Supreme court,
Liberal Democrats scream bloody murder
about the Legitimacy
of appointing a justice
this close to an election
while calling attention
to Barrett's Catholicism
and anti abortion animus.
- And it looks like having three
names is the only thing she
and her predecessor have in common.
- [narrator] But according to
Reason Senior Editor Jacob Sullum,
when it comes to criminal
justice and abortion,
the two may have far more in common than
Conservatives and
Progressive seem to realize.
- Ruth Bader Ginsburg was about as good
as you could reasonably expect a
quote unquote Liberal Justice to be.
She was generally sound
on the Fourth Amendment
on the first Amendment when it
came to issues of due process
and criminal justice cases in general.
[narrator] Despite being
attacked as a doctrinaire law
and order conservative Barrett says
Sullum has issued opinions that
track pretty well with Ginsburg
when it comes to limiting the police.
He points to one ruling in
particular in which Barrett found
that DEA agents didn't have
a right to search a property
when granted permission by a
woman who didn't live there.
- So therefore this was an invalid search
and therefore they can't use this evidence
against the drug suspect.
That's an example of a
decision that that would be
traditionally condemned by conservatives,
where you hear you're letting this guy
off on a technicality,
but in fact it's what the fourth Amendment
in my view at least requires.
So that's encouraging.
[narrator] In at least one
case involving a detective who
lied in a statement so
that he could arrest an
innocent man for murder.
Barrett came down hard on his
claim to qualified immunity
which shields law enforcement officers
from being sued for misconduct.
- And Barrett took credit said no way.
There's no way that you could have thought
it was okay to lie in a
probable cause affidavit.
The guy that you victimized should
have a chance to make that case in court.
- [narrator] When it comes to abortion.
Barrett has said that
she thinks it's unlikely
that the court will fully
overturn Roe V. Wade,
even as she has criticized the ruling as
an act of judicial overreach.
Ruth Bader Ginsburg had
similar reservations about
the landmark 1973 case.
- Ginsburg had two main
criticisms of Roe V. Wade.
One was that she didn't think it took
the right analytical approach,
instead of using this sort of vague notion
of privacy protected by
substantive due process
which really has no basis
in the constitution.
She thought it should have been
an equal protection argument
that abortion laws discriminate
against people based on sex.
And she also thought that the
Supreme court went too far
in preempting in a wholesale sort of way
state abortion laws.
Ginsburg thought that this led to
an unnecessary federalization
of the issue that
led to a great deal of
division and acrimony.
And if the court had left
a little bit more time
for the issue to work its way
through the democratic process
there wouldn't have been the
sense that the Supreme court
had arbitrarily overridden
the decision decisions of
State Legislators who are
trying to represent the
opinions of their Constituents.
And I think Barrett would
agree with a lot of that.
I honestly don't know how she's going to
approach abortion cases except to say that
she probably will be receptive
to upholding the sorts
of laws that are up to make their way to
the Supreme court,
which have to do not with wholesale bans
but with various kinds of restrictions.
- [narrator] On issues such as gun rights
and federalism,
Barrett would likely be much better
from a libertarian perspective.
- Ruth Bader Ginsburg, like
most people on the left
she had a blind spot when it
came to the second Amendment
which is after all part
of the bill of rights,
she agreed with her other
Liberal colleagues that
the second Amendment basically
does not impose any limits
on what governments can do
in terms of gun control.
The majority of course found otherwise
which I think was the right decision.
She was also bad when it came
to Congresses use of the Commerce Clause.
One was Obamacare where the issue was
can the federal government
under the pretext of regulating
interstate commerce say,
you must buy government
approved health insurance.
And there were some very
compelling arguments
against that notion.
This is not Interstate
Commerce for one thing.
Barrett is definitely
going to be better when
it comes to the second Amendment.
I suspect she will better when
it comes to property rights.
I'm almost certain she's
going to be better in terms
of defining Congress's powers
under the Commerce Clause.
So those are ways in which I
think she would definitely be
better from a libertarian perspective,
on Fourth Amendment she looks pretty good.
I can't say that she's
better than Ginsburg on
the Fourth Amendment.
Ginsburg was good.
But there are reasons to
think Barrett will be better
than Ginsburg on issues
that libertarians care about
and will be nearly as good or as good on
other issues that Progressives
tend to care about.